we have the very latest phone
conversations between Trump and Obama
from just the last couple of days here
they are hello Rach it's got old yes I
know you're still in charge of the Armed
Forces right until you're sworn in great
you know those military bands that are
now like the only musicians playing it
by inauguration yes
they just has to be recited got back
duty Afghanistan yeah
hey there I saw that you gave Joe by
what are those presidential medals our
freedom pretty cool
yes I did he deserved it so is there any
limit on how many of those things the
president could give away no there's
technically not a limit but it's our
nation's highest civilian honor so I
would caution you to that's not how it
works
oh and pegs - I don't want it to get
jealous abide and all of course need one
for myself
oh and do they make them for dog on a
collar ticking I get a job there are you
there
I think he's placing the order last
Kellyanne you want one movie really made
you cry oh no probably tea you cried at
et what a [ __ ] human Donald's only four
more days till the inauguration Labor
Act that's right I pretty excited yeah
listen I got you a gift for the big day
really what's that a yellow tie
true got that feedback sure Donald what
do you need
crap I'm getting another call hold on
for the man Gabriel in human is what you
really care this game they catch it
it's film about
[Applause]
you